[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce numéro de mode
d'emploi consacré à sky emploi organisé
le 4 avril prochain au vélodrome
nationale plusieurs viennent s'inviter
parmi nous autour de la table erwan le
gall conseiller communautaire délégué à
l'emploi et à l'insertion
professionnelle
michael gregorio diligente d'automation
de 2000 entreprises spécialisées dans la
conception de relais de protection de
transformateurs électronique basée à
coignières et nous accueillons aussi
cristiano et steve deux jeunes de 21 ans
suivis par la mission locale de ski ou
et 16,25 bonsoir à tous on se rassure
alors au programme de cette émission la
deuxième édition de sky emploi au
vélodrome nationale ce sera le 4 avril
de 9h à 20h30
au programme près de 150 entreprises
présent quatre mille offres d'emploi et
autant de visiteurs attendus pour des
entretiens d'embauché les détails dans
ce numéro
rencontre avec guillaume jennati la
trouver un emploi grâce à l'édition 2010
8,2 remplissent de pôle emploi puis
découverte de grandes visions un groupe
participant à cet événement alors ikhwan
lequel on va commencer avec vous quel
bilan vous tiré de en piste pour
l'emploi qu'elle ait lieu donc la
première édition en 2018 mais un très
bon bilan avec beaucoup de visiteurs
vous l'avez rappelé 4000 visiteurs 4000
noté à l'entrée je crois qu'il n'y a pas
de l'afssaps à un moment il y tellement
de monde le rush était tellement fort
que nous avons nous avons été obligés de
lever le rail de sécurité donc je pense
qu'on est plus sûr prêt des salles plus
près des 5000 70 % de personnes
satisfait de l'événement par rapport à
leurs attentes
c'est ça qu'il faut savoir et 60 % de
visiteurs venant du territoire
ça c'est important aussi de le dire un
bilan très positif
vraiment très positif parce que on s'est
rendu compte que un événement
exceptionnel de cette envergure là et
bien attirer beaucoup de monde mais
aussi était très parlants et susciter
l'envié l'engouement pour les chefs
d'entreprise donc c'est pour ça qu'à
deuxième édition était naturellement
obligatoire puis une troisième puis une
quatrième avec des axes d'amélioration
il faudra noter que sur
l'année 2019 donc le 4 avril il y aura
un espace dédié dans le recrutement qui
sera beaucoup plus grand que celui de
2018 alors avant d'aborder justement
l'édition 2019 je vous propose de
revenir en arrière vous avez dit qu'il y
avait un bilan positif il a été positif
aussi pour guillaume jennati qu'est venu
chercher un emploi lors de cet événement
l'année dernière il a obtenu un
entretien et décrocher un poste chez
generix group découverte de celui en
courtois reportage c'était il ya près
d'un an guillaume jennati 24 ans
employée dans une grande surface seront
vélodrome pour en piste pour l'emploi
son objectif trouver un emploi dans sa
filière de formation l'électronique
c'est un plus un événement qu un
entretien d'embauché
je me suis préparé par rapport à ce que
j'avais fait pendant ma période de
débuter donc me souvenir un petit peu de
tout ce que j'ai pu apprendre pendant la
période
tout ce que moi je recherchais en tout
cas dans le domaine électronique après
son dut dans le domaine électrique il
n'a pas réussi à trouver un emploi dans
ce domaine suite à en piste pour
l'emploi il a été embauché directement
en cdi chez generali ce groupe dans la
filiale axt reid
il est aujourd'hui technicien électrique
là on fait un petit schéma de pour faire
différentes cartes donc là -
principalement je dois faire une carte
une bande de l'aide là ici on fait tout
ce qui est chez m'a donc des cartes et
après on passera au labo pour contester
vérifier que les fonctionnalités sont
présentes
guillaume travaille pour différents
projets industriels ici une boîte
destinée au rangement de ski avec un
système électrique d'ouverture protéger
et automatique
le but c'est simplement avec une petite
carte de stations de ski on ne passe
devant un lecteur rfid et avec ce moteur
à cela il va nous donner l'autorisation
d'ouverture
je savais qu'il y avait un gros
potentiel après six mois voilà tous
savaient que c'était une perle rare
on a vraiment du mal en ce moment à
recruter des personnes dans l'ingénierie
électronique aux techniciens ou
ingénieurs est effectivement oui c'est
une perle rare
il a dépassé mes attentes pour son
évolution guillaume a comme projet de
suivre des cours du soir pour obtenir le
diplôme et le titre d'ingénieur chez
gennari ce groupe
alors cristiano et steve je me tourne
vers vous vous avez 21 ans vous avez un
bac pro en électrotechnique une
formation similaire à celle de guillaume
qu'est-ce que vous évoque son parcours
est ce que c'est un exemple pour vous
oui oui bien sûr c'est un exemple
pourquoi parce que en fait là réussi à
trouver un travail
hélas pas là pour trouver un travail
c'est assez compliqué il faut vraiment
donner les moyens
c'est ce que vous retenez de ça c'est
qu'il n'a pas baissé les bras
est ce que finalement en perdurant il
travaille dans un bon jour dans une
grande surface et puis finalement il a
réussi à trouver dans son domaine
d'activité comment vous vous préparer
justement un entretien déjà dans quel
secteur vous recherchez quelles sont les
compétences que vous mettez en avant
dans un entretien bah moi dans un
entretien j'ai déjà jeu je mets mon
expérience en avant et
j'essaie de rep et de fin de de répéter
un peu chez moi ce que je dois dire à
l'entretien et enfin sur internet j'ai
aussi une dizaine de grâce à ce crédit
local on va voir des images de l'atelier
2 cv notamment où vous apprenez à faire
des cv
oui c'est sûr nous apprend à faire des
cv comment comment comment parler dans
un entretien comment convaincre et les
employeurs et voilà
et qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'elle
comble essence vous mettez en avant qu
est ce que vous savez faire alors il
fait deux dindes à prendre déjà
d'apprendre le métier quand on arrive
bien con con à l'école et sur le terrain
c'est pas la même chose ni quelle faute
hors ue vous vous allez participer à ce
qu'ils emploient cette année on vous
êtes dirigeant de l'entreprise
automation 2000 vous recherchez 2 poste
de monteur câbleur alors quel profil
vous recherchez en réalité le profil moi
c'est avant tout des compétences
humaines qui m'intéresse parce qu'on est
dans même si on est dans le domaine de
l'électro mais les trous mécanique
les gens sont formés intégralement dans
la maison on est une entreprise
familiale qui a 40 ans d'expérience la
plupart des employés n'ont pas forcément
même pas le bac
et ils ont tous été intégralement formés
en interne donc pour moi c'est d'abord
des compétences humaines de travail le
travail d'équipé rigueur être capable
d'être habile de ses doigts parce que
forcément quand on est monteur câbleur
ou monteur quoi monteur câbleur ou ou
monteux scabreuses et bien forcément si
on est pas si on n'est pas habile de ses
doigts ça va pas le faire donc c'est
vraiment ça le sujet on est en train de
voir justement une infographie qui
indiquent un peu les particularités de
ce poste donc le compétences habiletés
manuelles manuel vous l'avait dit et
puis pas forcément pas besoin de
formations n'ont aucune formation
vraiment tout est fait en
on forme les gens de a à z mais bon
voilà ils vont apprendre à la soudure
ils vont apprendre à utiliser le rif
deux ils vont leur apprendre vraiment où
l'ensemble de ce qui nous permet de
fabriquer les appareils qu on
commercialise dans le monde entier alors
sky emploi 2019 ça va ressembler à quoi
herman le gall c'est dommage que j'ai
pas le temps de réagir sur les deux
interventions ce que c'est
extraordinaire si c'est ce qu'ils
allaient je me permets juste pour chef
d'entreprise il a compris une chose
essentielle essentiel c'est à dire que
c'est pas un diplôme par rapport à des
métiers en tension
mais c'est bien les compétences et le
savoir être et la formation en interne
et c'est comme ça c'est la clé de la
réussite et la deuxième chose sur
l'estrade aux estives
c'est que ils sont un peu intimidé je
pense parce que moi j'ai discuté un
petit peu avant de venir
ils sont beaucoup plus motivés que ça
très clairement c'est à dire qu'il est
ils ont bien juste de dire que ils sont
presque à deux doigts de signer un
contrat dont un chez decaux voilà donc
ça veut dire que l'accompagnement et
skyways 16 25 et se fait et c'est aussi
la clé c'est vous l'avez dit c'est aussi
la compét' les compétences et la
motivation
et ça ça fait deux ans que je le dis si
les jeunes motivés ils s'en sortent
voilà la clé elle est là elle et pas
ailleurs pour répondre à votre question
sur 2019
écoutez on va avoir un gros show de
recrutement qui va être une capacité qui
va être beaucoup plus grande que celle
de l'année dernière pour permettra aux
candidats et aux chefs d'entreprise
d'avoir aussi un peu plus d'espacé
liberté pour accueillir
les jeunes et les moins jeunes je
rappelle aussi que c'est ouvert à tout
le monde c'est pas une fourchette dédiés
aux 16 25 ans le 4 avril s'ouvrira tout
le monde y compris les salariés qui
veulent se reconvertir
et puis les seniors évidemment ça ses
premiers points après il y a toujours le
booster enfin toutes ces activités la
ville différentes zones sky recrute
c'est pour consulter les offres d'emploi
disponibles sur le terrain il ya un
showroom il ya un showroom
il y aura des centres de formation il y
aura les 20 ans du pli il y aura une
annonce importante que je ferai le matin
sur le territoire avec une annonce
vraiment qui est qui et qui est
essentielle pour pour l'emploi et il y
aura également le fil rouge avec des
tables rondes
voilà enfin sa tante de choses moi à
l'image animée emploi des ateliers des
témoignages justement de chefs
d'entreprise ou même de personnes qui
ont été recrutées les ressources aux 6
et les services qui sont proposés aux
saint quentinois par rapport à l'emploi
ça peut être est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui qui vous impressionne ce type
d'événement est ce que les entretiens
anglais c'est impressionnant où ça va
c'est du style vous vous disiez vous
préparer en vous entraînant chez vous
est ce que quand vous voyez un dirigeant
d'entreprise qui vous reçoit en face de
vous qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez leur
dire qu'est ce que vous souhaitez leur
montrer bah je souhaite le dauphin enfin
je souhaite montrer ma détermination
intégré l'entreprise
pardon et voilà je vais j'essaie de
mettre mes cartes dé toutes les tares de
sur deux côtés pour ton côté du haillan
de côté là sur mon côté
c'est ça mickey c'est quoi un et un
entretien idéal pour vous qu'est ce que
vous attendez à l'entretien idéal comme
on l'a déjà le cv on voit déjà les
compétences qu'ils ont sur le papier ce
qui pour moi est vraiment essentiel
c'est de voir l'humain qu'on a en face
de nous voir si la personne en effet
elle et elle est motivée
si parce que le cv nous dit si vous
savez faire ou pas mais c'est vraiment
la compétence humaine parce qu'un
travail d'équipé ça s'invente pas vous
pouvez être bardé de diplômes
si vous savez pas travailler en équipe
comment vous intégrez quelqu'un qui est
super intelligent super cultivé et qui
derrière ne fonctionne pas dans l'équipe
non c'est vraiment l'humain qui est le
plus important or justement l'humain il
ya aussi important dans le métier du
commerce
et c'est un secteur source d'emplois
notamment chez les opticiens de nouveaux
magasins recherche dans ce domaine c'est
le cas du groupe grandvision pour ces
trois enseignes une entreprise présente
sur saint quentin en yvelines
elle va participer aussi à sky emploi
découverte des postes proposés les
images sont signés marylène iapichino
niveau la monture ne veut plus au
suspense en monture autour non plutôt
cercle est complètement d'accord
s'intéresser aux clients l'accompagner
dans ses choix pour vendre des lunettes
l'activité commerciale de l'opticien
c'est aussi être spécialiste de
l'optique pour déterminer les bons
verres pour la bonne vision
j'avais besoin des doutes concernant le
départ je voulais faire un plateau à
votre disposition son savoir faire une
sélection des mentions on va beaucoup
travailler avec les rebelles après il ya
tout ce que préparation des lunettes
préparation aussi de
des livraisons entretien au magasin à
aimer le métier mais aussi côté médical
sont nés en même en lien avec un aspect
très médicale aura les yeux la santé
visuelle
c'est une chose de très important donc
faut être consciencieux
et puis rigoureux bien sûr pour ses
magasins grandvision va proposer de
nombreux postes d'opticiens lors de sky
emploi avec différents profils
recherchés technicien optique ou vendeur
un opticien diplômé peut faire justement
tout ce qui est à vérification visuelle
et adaptation aux lentilles de contact
contrairement à l'opticien hollander pas
principalement faire des ventes dans le
solaire authentique vente lunettes
des stages et des alternances sont aussi
proposés dans les magasins situés à
montigny le bretonneux le siège de
grands vision propose ce type de contrat
aux étudiants en marketing ressources
humaines ou communication des offres
disponibles le 4 avril prochain sur leur
stand lors du sky emploi avant de
conclure cette émission un rappel pour
vous inscrire à sky emploi vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site sky emploi.fr
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
c'est le 4 avril prochain donc tout le
monde peut s'inscrire un entrepreneur
chef d'entreprise est aussi demandeurs
d'emploi jeunes ou moins jeunes
merci à tous les quatre d'être venu sur
notre plateau et merci à vous de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve le mois
prochain à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]